الان الى ملف التوتر الشماليه كوسوفو حيث
قالت شرطه ان اشتباكات انضارت بين الشرطه
ومواطنين من القوميه الصربيه حاولوا
السيطره على مبنى بلديه
البلاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع اصوات
انفجارات جرائم قنابل الصوت والغاز
المسيله للدموع في محيط المكان بالاضافه
الى طلقات ناريه
كما شهدت البلده مواجهات بين الاقليات
الصربيه وقوات حفظ السلام التي يقودها حلف
الشمال الاطلسي في كوسوفو في محيط مبنى
البلديه ما ادى الى اصابه اكثر من 30
عنصرا من الحلف
وبينما اكد رئيس وزراء كوسوفو حق
المسؤولين في بلديات الشمال بتولي مناصبهم
دون ترهيب دعم نظيره الصربيه المجتمع
الدولي الى ضمان ان يصير بكوسوفو وبينما
حتى الاتحاد الاوروبي وكوسوفو والمحتاجين
على التهدئه دون قيدنا وشرط عززت قوات
النيت وجودها في اربع مناطق شماليه
الاقليم